the Irishman is here oh not that one or
that one sorry yes that one Martin
Scorsese's latest film based off the
book I heard you paint houses tells the
story of Frank the Irishman Sheeran an
alleged hitman for the Bufalino crime
family who just months before his death
confessed to the murder of Jimmy Hoffa
but did he actually do it and what
details to the film change or leave out
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into the ending and the real-life
mobsters who shaped Frank's life but to
understand the ending one must first go
to the beginning in fact this is the
first shot we the viewer in a darkened
hallway almost as if were in a dark
Theater about to be told a tale from the
film's protagonist Frank Sheeran in fact
the floating point of view shot here
suggests we're looking at this from
Charles Brandt's perspective but who's
Charles Brandt well he's the former
private investigator who wrote the book
the movie is based on and to whom Frank
confessed
we are him about to meet Frank who's
gonna tell us his life story
for Frank this is his way at seeking
some sort of redemption although in my
humble opinion it's too little too late
the final shot of him is sad him small
framed between an almost closed door
just like his life which is soon coming
to an end for those of you wondering he
died in 2003 at the age of 83 refusing
to eat following his final videotaped
confession it's estimated that he killed
over two dozen people even more if you
count as time in the war alone in the
old folks cafeteria we get a glimpse of
two important accessories Frank's watch
and ring a symbol of the two most
important relationships in his life the
ring he got from Russell Bufalino and
the watch from Jimmy Hoffa these two men
shaped his life made him do terrible
things and yet he still wears these
pieces but why let's start with Russell
Bufalino portrayed by Joe Pesci in his
best work since home alone born Rosario
Alberto Bufalino Russell became head of
the Northeastern Bufalino crime family
in Pennsylvania which he ruled from 1959
to 1989 the Bufalino had strong ties to
the National Cosa Nostra criminal
society another name for the Mafia this
is depicted through his strong
relationship with Anthony Fat Tony
Salerno the underboss of the Genovese
crime family which ruled over much of
New York in Philadelphia the ring which
he gives to Frank the night of his
Teamsters Man of the Year award is a
symbol of his trust and only three
people have it him Angelo Bruno and now
Frank Angelo Bruno portrayed by Harvey
Keitel was the head of one of
Philadelphia's crime families he was
known as the gentle Don because he
preferred conciliation over violence
even though he was later killed by a
shotgun blast in the back of the head
three people have this ring and you know
what frank says about three people
usually three people could keep a secret
and only when told I'm a dead writer
Steve Zaillian proceeds the ring scene
with Frank receiving his gold watch from
Jimmy Hoffa it's not a coincidence these
two scenes are put back-to-back two
different gifts from people he considers
father figures he even says that
receiving this award from Jimmy is quote
the highlight of his life so the
highlight of her life isn't getting
married or having kids that's gotta hurt
if you're part of his family and the
toll his work takes on his family
especially his daughter Peggy is evident
as a child Peggy never got along with
Russell even though Russell tried his
best to make her happy
differently she don't like me like she's
afraid to me perhaps she could sense
something bad about him about the things
he made her father do Jimmy on the other
hand is adored by her she even does a
great school paper about how he and the
Union help working families in her eyes
Jimmy is a good man he may be a bit
corrupt but at the end of the day he's
helping the working man that's why when
his death is announced she knows it's
her father who did it Frank not
immediately calling Jimmy's wife after
the news is all she needs to know to put
two and two together from that day on as
Frank describes she ceased talking to
him later on in life Frank visits her
had her job only for her to walk away
his daughter has completely disowned him
later when he talks to his other
daughter Delores he has the opportunity
to open up and be honest to ask for
forgiveness but he doesn't he does
appear being a bad father saying he was
just trying to protect them but he's
oblivious to the extent of damage he's
already caused can I come to you for
protection because of the terrible thing
that you would do ironically Frank's
need to protect his children became the
thing they feared most from him this is
encapsulated in the scene where Frank
finds out the grocery store owner pushed
Peggy he brings her to the store to
watch him beat the crap out of him the
event however that defines Frank's life
is the murder of Jimmy Hoffa a man who
gave Frank his first big job and would
later make him president of one of his
local unions the real Jimmy Hoffa was in
fact involved with organized crime the
movie going over much of his hatred for
John F Kennedy whose brother Bobby then
Attorney General of the United States
was trying to bring him down he hated
the Kennedys so much that after John's
assassination he orders the Teamsters
Union not to fly the flag at half-mast
this hatred for Kennedy was not well
liked by the Mafia who supported Kennedy
since they thought a counter-revolution
in Cuba led by a Kennedy supported us
may get their casinos back in Havana
Jimmy mysteriously disappeared in 1975
while waiting to have a meeting with
Anthony provenzano and Anthony
Jacqueline a sorry for how bad my
Italian pronunciations are but unlike
the film which offers one version as to
what happened to Jimmy his case is still
considered unsolved the last person to
have any contact with him was his
unofficial appointment secretary Louie
Lynn toe who he called from a pay phone
to vent his frustration while the two
tony's were an hour late the next day
his unlocked car was found in the
parking lot and to this day his body has
never been recovered
aughter still is the next morning when
hafez wife told her daughter he was
missing the daughter told her that she
had a vision that he was already dead
wearing a dark-colored short sleeve polo
just like what he's wearing in a film
version not mentioned in the film is the
confession of another hitman richard
kuklinski also known as the Iceman who
claims to have killed Hoffa by putting
his body in a barrel and crushing it
along with used car parts into a metal
cube before shipping it off to Japan
there is however no evidence to back
this claim former New York mobster
Michael Franzese in a 20-19 interview
claimed to know where hafez body is as
well as the identity of the shooter
stating that the hit was mafia related
in that hafez body is quote somewhere
very wet and that the shooter is still
alive but currently in prison Frank's
story the one we see in the film
hafez murder occurring in a house in
detroit but when investigators examine
bloodstains found in that house the
results did not match hafez why would
Frank kill him is another question why
kill the man who had been so good to you
who on multiple occasions professed his
love Frank had no other choice the
higher-ups in the crime family wanted
Hoffa gone for jeopardizing their
relationship with the Teamsters Union if
Hoffa had become president of the Union
again it would not be good for business
not to mention all the files and dirt he
has on the Mafia Jimmy had to go and
it's heavily implied that Frank was to
go to but it was Russell who intervened
on his behalf with the crime family
agreeing to let Frank live if he was the
one to pull the trigger the only reason
they agreed to this respect to me but
uranium okay this all goes back to
protection how far are you willing to go
to protect those you love Frank didn't
have to go through with it but doing so
would put him and his family in the
Mafia's crosshairs but it's not just one
decision that totally changed his life
it was a series of decisions starting
with some small-time snake stealing this
led to him doing bigger crimes like
almost blowing up a linen warehouse
which he didn't know his pal Angelo
Bruno partly owned this led to him
killing a man named whispers and this
event became the gateway for him to take
on more and more hits for the mob
Frank's decision to do these things were
driven by money money he needed for his
family holding news you got more kids in
turn Frank ended up neglecting his
family leaving his first wife and
scarring his children who lived in
constant fear his wife died of lung
cancer but I guess that makes sense
considering all those smoke breaks they
took essentially Frank is left all alone
Russell who he ends up spending time
with in prison is depicted in the film
as dying after attending quote Church
and knowing how these guys have code
words like painting houses it can be
assumed to die in real life however he
was released from prison in the late 80s
where he later died in hospital at the
age of 90
Russell's post prison life which acts as
a epilogue to the film deals with Frank
coming to terms with his life we've
already seen how his family has disowned
him and now that he's failed his faith
Emily his own body is failing him as
well he goes to pick out his own casket
a green one fitting for an Irishman he
chooses a plot in the crypt number 1948
the same year he began working for
Russell he talks about choosing to be
buried over cremation saying that's the
hottest part of anybody when they
berries when they go into the ground
because it's so final he's concerned
being cremated is too final but perhaps
his fear of the finality of death has
not so much to do with death itself but
dying before one's story is told there's
something still on his conscious thus
his eventual decision to confess his
story going back to this idea being
buried is encapsulated in the scene
where Frank as a world war ii soldier
makes his captors dig their own graves
before killing them Frank metaphorically
is just like these soldiers digging his
own grave but the decisions he makes
throughout the film hell he even gets to
choose his own casket it's crazy but I
never understood how they just keep
digging their own graves you know when
the federal agents come and ask him who
he's protecting by remaining silent they
tell him everyone around him is dead all
the people that once could bring harm to
his family are gone he confesses
although not every detail to a priest
with arguably one of the most cryptic
lines of the film he's referring to the
heartbreaking call he had with Jimmy's
wife one in which he stutters
uncontrollably he's supposed to be the
one consoling yet he looks like the one
who should be consoled it's pathetic sad
and this line sums up his guilt
Frank is surprised that the nurse has no
idea who Jimmy Hoffa is a man he says
was more well known in the 60s than the
Beatles if no one remembers Jimmy who
will remember him in fact when the
priest says a prayer absolving him of
his sins a scene that is implied happens
after his confession to Charles Brandt
the priest informs him that Christmas is
coming up but Frank is oblivious he has
no family to celebrate with he has lost
everything the final shot is a sad
portrayal of a man whose life has turned
to tragedy of his own doing iLife that
soon to be closed just like that door
thanks for watching everyone if you like
this video please leave a
and let me know what you thought of the
Irishman in the comments below I'll be
coming up with more videos so make sure
to subscribe with that Belon and you can
also follow me on twitter at big story
whitey until next time remember daddy
loves you very much